So, auf geht's!
Ah, exzellent. Ähm, ah guck mal da, der Sebaru ist auch da. Ich hab jetzt grad den
Chat refreshed, ich hab gar nicht gesehen, wer alles da ist.
Wahrscheinlich die üblichen Verdächtigen. Der geht immer. Der geht echt immer.
Äh, was ich grad noch im Chat gesehen hab, ist, irgendjemand hat gefragt, wie das mit...
Ich weiß nicht, ob ich noch ein paar Voter davon bin oder ob ich schon die Fritzbox bestellt
hab, hat irgendjemand gefragt. Ja, also ich hab die Fritzbox noch nicht bestellt, weil
der Covid Simulator, ja genau, den brauchen wir jetzt noch unbedingt. Ist eh schon alles
voll mit Nachrichten und Leute, die die ganze Nacht nur über Covid labern. Hab ich euch
eigentlich erzählt, dass ich mir versucht hab Covid, dass ich mir, langsam Max, dass
ich mir versucht habe, also mega big brain move eigentlich, dass ich mir versucht habe
Covid 20 und Covid 21 Usernamen zu sichern und Domains zu registrieren. Hat leider nicht
geklappt, die waren schon alle weg. Ich hab gedacht, das bleibt jetzt noch eine Weile
erhalten, also registrierst du dir mal covid20.de, covid21.de, covid21.biz. Sogar fucking covid20.biz
ist belegt. Nee, nee, nee, die hab ich nicht. Die mit Bindestrich, das war irgendeine komische,
was war denn das? Covid-20.best, das ist ja die bescheuertste Domain dafür überhaupt.
Punkt best. Ja, also zum thema, zum thema Fritzbox. Ja, also zum thema, hab ich die gar nicht
in Eingang. Welche wollte ich kaufen? Die da, die da wollte ich kaufen. Genau, aber nicht
auf lager, na super, jetzt hab ich's verkackt, kann ich nicht mehr kaufen. Nein, danke. Also
zum thema Fritzbox, ich hab mir noch keine Fritzbox bestellt. Das liegt nämlich daran,
dass ich den Vodafone geantwortet hab. Stell euch das mal vor. Und die haben sich aber gedacht,
ich les euch mal vor, ich les euch mal vor, was Vodafone geantwortet hat. So, ich muss
mal messages aufmachen, Vodafone hat geantwortet. Ähm, oh nee, geh weg, C++, ah, weg. So, also,
Vodafone hat geschrieben, blablabla, lieber, lieber Kunde Unity Media Etc. Vodafone, willkommen
bei uns, blablabla, wir haben ihr Anliegen aufgenommen und melden uns schnellstmöglich
bei ihnen, vielen Dank für die Geduld. So, und dann kam gestern noch ne Nachricht gleich
hinterher, ähm, lieber Kunde, ihre Störung wird durch ein externes Störsignal in ihrer
Nähe verursacht. Da hab ich mir schon so gedacht, klingt mal wieder nach Ausrede. Ähm, bitte
haben sie noch etwas Geduld, wir melden uns, sobald die Störung beseitigt wurde, vielen
Dank für ihr Verständnis. Danach hab ich nix mehr gehört von Vodafone und heute Morgen
kam ne Mail, ob ich nicht an der Umfrage teilnehmen möchte, wie zufrieden ich mit dem Kundenservice
bin. Also, ich hab's nicht ausgefüllt, weil ich hab keine Ahnung, ob das Problem weg
ist. Es wär ja nicht schlecht, wenn sich irgendjemand, irgendjemand gesagt hätte, ok, es ist abgeschlossen,
wir, sie können jetzt wieder normal benutzen oder so, ne? Vodafone gedacht, nein. Das ist...
Hatsi, haben sie sich gedacht, ja? Aber trotzdem, es klingt halbwegs plausibel, mal gucken,
mal gucken, wir werden es ja sehen, Leute, wir werden es ja sehen, ob, ähm, dompc sagt,
Störsignale gibt es oft bei Kabel, wo kommen die dann her? Ich muss bei Kabel immer daran
denken, wie man früher noch bei, kennt noch jemand, kennt jemand noch diese Dinger? Hat
das noch irgendjemand mitbekommen, der so in meinem Alter ist? Was Störsignale, muss
jemand daran denken, wenn einer so ein Ding nicht aufgesteckt hat? Das ist, das ist hochgradige
Boomer-Technologie hier, das Ding, zumindest was Netzwerk angeht. Damals hat man, ähm,
Oszilloskop hat einen BNC-Stecker, das ist auch noch sowas, was ich irgendwann mir mal
eins holen wollte, ich weiß noch nicht genau, was ich mitmachen soll, aber so ein Oszilloskop
hätt ich auch mal gern. Also, und, ähm, muss ich noch was für, was man damals hat,
ist BNC und T-Stück, weiß gar nicht, wie das Ding auf Englisch hieß, das war zu Zeiten,
da hab ich die Sachen noch nicht auf Englisch gesucht. Oh, guck mal, gibt's ja immer noch,
BNC-T-Stück. Ja, hoho, das hat man früher an die Netzwerkkarte gemacht. Also, das kam
an die Netzwerkkarte, auf der einen Seite kam so ein Abschlusswiderstand hin und auf
der anderen Seite das BNC-Kabel zum nächsten Netzwerkkabel. Das war, das war wirklich,
ziemlich ja kacke. Hier sieht man's mal, wie das aussah mit dem Netzwerkkabel. 10Base2,
wusste gar nicht, wie der Kram heißt. Gab's dafür eigentlich auch Switche? Widerspricht
zwar eigentlich dem Sinn, aber man weiß ja nie. Gab es, gab es, äh, 10Base2-Switche,
gab's sowas? Scheiße, sowas gab's wirklich. Ach du große Kacke. Sowas gab's, aber das
sieht genauso boomer aus, wie die Leute, die den Kram noch verwenden. Oh Mann. Du hast
ein USB-Osteloskop aus, aus China. Aus China, sozusagen. Ein Osteloskop aus China und taugt
das? Na, man könnte damit doch ohne Probleme den Switch machen. Einfach 1 zu 1 Verbindungen
damit machen. Ist zwar bescheuert mit dem Medium, aber warum nicht? Täglich bei STI-Kameras
hat es schon nie in der Hand. Kabel kann auch den Mobilfunk stören. Echt. Die Technik
wird mir immer sympathischer. Ähm, ich wollte dann eigentlich schon viel früher anfangen.
Ich hab den Streamtitel irgendwie geändert vor 3 Stunden und dann hab ich noch gedacht,
ach komm, ne halbe Stunde Stream guckste noch, fängst dann irgendwie so 18 oder sonst was
an und dann bin ich bei, äh, bei Daffran, Daffran, Alter, Daffran oder wie er jetzt
genau ausspricht, hängen geblieben und hab mir ein Valorant Tournament angeguckt, 2
Runden. Und dann hab ich gedacht, gut, jetzt ist es schon 20.40 Uhr, jetzt lohnt es sich
auch nicht mehr, aber scheiß drauf, komm jetzt mal. Jetzt mach noch mal Stream an, ja.
Und ich hab wirklich nix im Sinne heute Sinnvolles zu machen, ja. Spiele auch mal Valorant,
ich hab kein Account, ich hab mich auch nicht registriert, ich hab kein Riot-Account, ich
hab keine Keys irgendwie geleashed im Stream. Das Einzige, was ich machen könnte ist, darf
man ja wahrscheinlich nicht, aber man macht jeder und der im Zweifel, also ich könnte
auf Ebay gehen und mir ein Account kaufen. Stimmt es, dass Valorant Anti-Cheat China
meine Nudes gibt. Was? Wie soll es das geben? Aber wenn du welche auf der Platte hast, haben
die die mittlerweile bestimmt. Aber nicht nur, aber nicht nur die, aber nicht nur die,
sondern die anderen auch alle, also deswegen ist das nicht so wild, es war schon verbreitet
genug vorher. Der Tribolone ist auch am Start, Patrick ist auch da, der Nightbot ist auch
da. xDxDxD, so, Nightbot, genau. Noch ne Idee für die Liste, keine Ahnung ob du es schon
hast gemacht hast, Arch plus DWM. Da stellt sich mir die Frage. Bäh, Nordpad, da stellt
sich mir die Frage, wo ist mein, naja, Windows und Dateien, ja. So, ähm, was, DWM. Was tun
wir hier? Eine Stunde, eineinhalb Stunden streamen oder gehe ich pennen? Wir gucken uns erst
ein paar übrig gebliebenen Fragen vom letzten Stream an, wir hatten ja mal Zeit. Äh, Tribolone
und ich auch. Heute, ich bin heute am Main ne Runde spazieren gegangen und da war wieder
der komplette Strand fort. Strand ist zu viel gesagt, wir haben am Main so zwei, drei Buchten
mit ein bisschen Sand und da sitzen die ganzen Outdoor-Boomer-Pepegas rum, Wufftschmann am
Strand und stecken sich an. Das ist, das ist auch wieder so ein Ding, ne? Irgendwie gibt's
kaum Leute, die da noch halbwegs normal ticken im Kopf. Du hast einmal die Fraktion, so nach
dem Motto, ähm, Bill Gates, ist der, ist der Corona-Mann oder gar, dass Vire nicht existieren
oder alles, alles nur, äh, staatlich verorderte Fake-News, ja? Sondern hast du auf der anderen
Seite, die sagen, ne, also, äh, jegliche Corona-Maßnahmen sind gerechtfertigt. Gibt's, gibt's eigentlich
noch ein paar normale Leute im Kopf? So irgendwas, so Leute, die sagen, okay, wir verstehen,
wir haben es eingesehen, dass die Lage ernst ist, aber zumindest sollte man sich mal über
die Maßnahmen Gedanken machen. Oh, das, das ist Weep-Musik. Ach ne, das ist, das, das
ist das Skyward Sword Intro, das ist doch keine Weep-Musik. Naja, doch, doch, eigentlich
schon, wenn man genau ist. Wie soll der Mittelweg gehen? Ja, einfach LTE statt 5G, ist doch
einfach. Oh, ja, die Schweizer nehmen das ernst, Patrick, wie es aussieht. Zum Türma,
Störungen, Kabel, Mobilfunk. Aha, ist das ein Vortrag? Ah ne, ah doch. Okay, der schaut
aus, als müsste das. Oh ne, das ist mir jetzt, der Vortrag ist mir jetzt ein Ticken, ein
Ticken zu lange für ein Stream. Aber der hat bestimmt Ahnung, der sieht pro aus. Speichel
mit das mal. Zum Thema Boomer-Technik, ich kenne jemand, der seine Modelleisenbahn auch
über Relays ansteuert. Wie macht man das denn sonst aktuell? Ich habe von Modelleisenbahn
nur wirklich keine Ahnung. Ich wusste gar nicht, dass es noch Modelleisenbahn Leute
gibt. Der angeblich das schnellsteigende Hobby weltweit ist Drone-Racing, habe ich
gelesen. Und das ist so ein Ding, das, das, das würde ich auch gerne mal ausprobieren.
Drone-Racing, dann hast du eine ordentliche Brille, ja, da kannst du mit Drone-Racing,
da kannst du mit Filme gucken, da kannst du mit VR-Porn gucken, da kannst du mit Sachen
spielen. Ne, ich glaube mit der Brille für Drone-Racing kannst du keine Filme gucken.
Dafür müsstest du aber das Haus verlassen. Ja, das ist richtig, aber ich kann bestimmt
auch von meinem Dach aus Drone-Racing. Seit wann ist das Chat, seit wann das Chat-Overlay
so transparent ist? Das ist eine gute Frage, da erkennt man ja kaum was, oder? Was ist
mit dem Chat, was ist da los? Oder erkennt man da was? Sagt mal Leute, ist das, ist das
besser so oder, oder war das vorher besser mit dem, mit dem dunklen Chat? Ich muss das
grad mal selbst ins Vollbild machen, dass ich da überhaupt noch was erkenne. Warte mal,
1080p, etwas zu, ne, das sieht gut aus, gefällt mir. Na wobei, ne, ganz so gut sieht das aus.
Ich weiß woran das liegt, ich kanns euch sagen, und zwar, ich hab grad nur so getan, als wüsste
ichs nicht. Ich grad mal hier die Qualität wieder runter, ich hab euch gebadet, ich
weiß natürlich woran das liegt, und zwar weil ich das vorhin umgestellt hab. So, und
das kann man umstellen jetzt nicht in Dark, sondern in, äh, ich glaub Better Twitch
TV Dark, und dann sagen wir Refresh, und jetzt sollte es besser aussehen eigentlich. So
Chat, probiert mal aus, ob es jetzt besser funktioniert. Ne oder, ist immer noch so komisch
transparent. Ich muss den Hintergrund weiß machen, äh, gehts ja noch schlechter als
vorher. Wartet mal. Moment, das muss ich jetzt grad mal ausprobieren. Ah, ich hab das,
ich hab das falsch geschrieben. Ich hab das falsch geschrieben, Leute. Ich bin ein Kacknoob.
Ich hab das falsch geschrieben. Das heißt nicht Better Twitch TV Dark, das heißt Better
Twitch TV Dark, und dann funktioniert das auch. Aha, guckt, jetzt ist es dunkel. Seht
ihr das? Pock. So ist es besser, ne? So ist das gut. So war es vorher nämlich auch.
Also, wie gesagt, ich hab's mal aufgeschrieben. Wir haben jetzt ein Vodafone-Emote auf dem
Discord. Ja, das hab ich gesehen, das ist ziemlich gut. Wobei ich das obere Omega-Lul
wegmachen würde, dass man das Vodafone größer sieht. Google Notes, weil ich kein Google
Zeug verwende für meinen privaten Kram. Wie viel, oh, das ist ne Frage. Wie viele Netzwerkeräte
hast du in, ach du Scheiße. Boah, keine Ahnung. Das ist so viel Zeug, das weiß ich ja aus
dem Kopf nicht. Kein Schimmer. Okay, okay, also probieren wir das mal. Fangen wir erstmal
an. Ne Kamera im Hof, ne Kamera oben, da wo die Katze immer schläft, ne Kamera unten
im Flur, ne Kamera an der Eingangstür, okay. Zwei Ubiquiti Access Points, ne 10G-Switch,
ne 8-Port 1G-Switch, ne Mikrotik-Router, ne Connectbox, ne Fritzbox, dann, keine Ahnung,
jetzt einmal 15 Raspberry Pi ESP32 und Raspberry Pi Zero und Odroid-Dinger, so Single-Board
und Mikro-Controller-Dinger, die 4HE-Server-Kiste, 2HE-Server-Kiste, 2 Desktop-Rechner, Notebook,
keine Ahnung, 8 Tablets oder so, 2 Smartphones, ach du Scheiße, keine Ahnung, das kriege
ich nicht alles zusammen. Geil, ne, das war jetzt das beste, was ich auf dem Kopf hingekriegt
habe. Wahrscheinlich war es das auch. Wahrscheinlich war es das auch. Aber das ist wirklich schwer
zu beantworten gerade. Ne, die 8 Tablets sind nicht permanent an, das hat sich halt mittlerweile
so angesammelt. Ich habe 2 Shield-Tablets, die Dinger, falls ihr noch jemand kennt, die
fand ich für ihre Zeit eigentlich ziemlich gut, diese Dinger, die Shield-Tablets, wobei
die halt, ich finde es doof, dass Nvidia nie ein neues Shield-Tablet gemacht hat. Hat
jemand einen Tipp für einen Server-Anbieter? Kommt doch an, was du brauchst, was brauchst
du denn? Also ich habe bisher immer alles mal digital ausgemacht, wenn ich viel Power
gebraucht habe für kurze Zeit. In Zukunft werde ich es mal mit der Hetzer-Cloud probieren,
weil die kostet einfach teilweise fast nur ein Drittel von digital aus. Da hole ich mir
mein Zeug normalerweise. Das lohnt sich aber nur, wenn man halt kurzzeitig fette Power
auf. Dann ist es aber richtig gut, weil, guck mal sich das hier mal an, Droplets, Pricing,
Standard. So, da kriegst du zum Beispiel, das Ding hier habe ich letztens gebucht, entweder
habe ich das Ding oder das Ding gebucht, ich glaube das Ding habe ich letztens gebucht,
halt aber nur für 3-4 Stunden und was habe ich denn am Ende bezahlt, irgendwie 3-4 Dollar,
das ist halt praktisch. Und die Handhabung von diesen Web-Interfaces ist halt auch super,
das ist total einfach. Machst einen Account, create, bam, kriegst einen Key, Ubuntu einloggen
und auf gehts. Für den ganzen Monat ist das natürlich nichts, dafür sind 480 Euro ein
bisschen viel. Selbst mit YouTube-Money. Der ganze Dong ist nicht relevant, nur hier.
Okay, gucken wir uns mal nach. Ich weiß nicht, ich muss jetzt irgendwas machen, was mich interessiert.
Jetzt schlafe ich ein, ich bin schon so spät am Start heute. Max flexed uns. Ey, halt gefragt,
wie viele Netzwerkgeräte ich hab. Also, zu den Tablets wollte ich doch kurz was sagen.
Wie gesagt, es haben sich 2 Shield Tablets angesammelt, davon geht aber nur eins, weil
das andere wurde ausgetauscht, weil ja angeblich der Akku explodiert. Es erinnert sich vielleicht
noch Leute dran, dass der Akku vom Shield Tablet ein bisschen zu heiß wurde. Aber das
habe ich aus in der Ecke stehen, das kann ich jederzeit anmachen. Es gibt nämlich einen
Fix dafür, falls jemand auch sein Shield Tablet ausgetauscht hat, es gibt einen Fix. Also,
wer sich traut sein Shield Tablet weiter zu betreiben, trotzdem dass der Akku eventuell
brennen kann, kann das hier machen. Ich würde es aber nicht machen, ich würde es aber nicht
machen, weil wie gesagt, wenn dann euer Haus abbrennt habt ihr gelitten. Keine Garantie
und so für nix. NVIDIA auch nicht. NVIDIA hat es ja Big Brain gemacht, so sollten es
eigentlich alle machen. NVIDIA hat gesagt, unser Shield Tablet ist verbackt, da brennt
der Akku, schicke uns einfach die Seriennummer und du kriegst ein neues. Habe ich gemacht
und sobald das neue Tablet das erste Mal ins Internet geht, schickt NVIDIA an das alte
Tablet, nen OTA, was den Bootloader flasht. Eigentlich ne gute Idee, also sprich, sobald
das neue in Betrieb genommen wurde, geht das alte kaputt. Eigentlich keine schlechte Idee.
Natürlich kann man das halt verhindern, indem man den Kill Switch killt, indem man quasi
das NVIDIA Tablet auch nachdem es deaktiviert wurde weiter benutzen kann. Aber wie gesagt
kann ich keinem empfehlen, falls einer noch so ein altes Ding rumliegen hat, weil wenn
der Akku abbrennt ist halt scheiße. Aber die Idee ist schon ziemlich Big Brainy von NVIDIA.
Aber wenn euch das egal ist, dass das Haus abbrennt, dann macht was ihr wollt. Genau,
also zu den Tablets. Es haben sich einfach ein paar Tablets mit den, ich weiß gar nicht
ob 8 reicht, mit den Jahren angesammelt. Also 2 Shield Tablets, nen Tegra Node 1, nen Olus
Lenovo, nen Asus Tablet, Asus, sorry, Asus, was mich auch sehr schwer enttäuscht hat.
Das Asus Tablet, dafür nenne ich jetzt Asus, weil das mögen sie überhaupt nicht, das
Asus Tablet, das hat mich sehr enttäuscht. Das war eigentlich ein ganz gutes Tablet für
über 53€, also sprich, das war mal ein Android Tablet, wo man sagen kann, ey, das ist ganz
gut, allerdings leider auch ähnlich preislich wie ein iPad. Zumindest haben die mich schwer
enttäuscht. Die Software, die sie mitgeliefert haben, war absoluter Crap und die haben nie
Firmware Updates gebracht, nie. Einfach komplett rausgebracht das Tablet und quasi einen Monat
später eingestellt. So, und da hab ich mir gedacht, fickt euch, ihr könnt mich mal am
Arsch lecken, kauf ich mir nicht mehr. Und jetzt hab ich mir zwei iPads noch. Also, weiter.
Also, ein Asus Tablet hatten wir, ein Tegra Tablet hatten wir schon, nen iPad und nen
Fire HD 10 oben, nen Fire HD unten, nen Fire HD 8 und nen iPad. So, neun, oder? Ne, elf.
Keine Ahnung, es sind mittlerweile elf Tablets, Alter. Yolo. Aber davon verwenden wir halt
eins, zwei, zwei. iPad und das Fire HD 8. Und, ähm, und halt oben und unten das Fire
HD 10 als, das habt ihr ja schon gesehen, das hab ich euch ja schon hier gezeigt, das
Fire HD 10 als, ähm, Dashboard an der Wand, ja. Das tue ich jetzt einfach mal nicht mitzuverwenden,
das ist halt an und zeigt Kameras an und zeigt Home Assistant, Dashboard und sowas an. Aber
es ist halt, da ist jetzt ein Tablet, also es ist auch an. So. Ist das Pinephone was
für dich hab ich mir noch gar nicht angeguckt, was ist denn das Pinephone? Ne, ich will,
das ist eh nix für mich. Ich will kein Smartphone selbst bauen, ich will ein Smartphone, das
funktioniert. Da drauf läuft ja im Endeffekt da nix, ne? Da läuft da wahrscheinlich, das
ist ja wahrscheinlich wieder kein Android, sondern irgendwas Eigengestricktes, gibt's
keine gescheiten Apps für, ähm, wird wahrscheinlich alles außer dem Preis zacken, also der Preis
wird viel zu hoch sein und wahrscheinlich wird er erst zacken. Ähm, es gab ja schon
so ein paar Versuche in der Richtung und das hat halt leider nie hingehauen, deswegen,
ich bleib, ich bleib bei, bei iOS und bei Android. Ein Fire HD oben und unten, das seh
die rum, ich hab's doch gerade gezeigt, der Chat gebated, gebated mich wieder. Das ist
das Dashboard oben an der Wand und unten ist natürlich noch mal genau das gleiche, ne?
Gegensprechanlage von der Tür und das Dashboard daneben, unten ist das Dashboard, da hat das
Kabel ein bisschen schöner, ich hab nämlich kein kurzes USB-Kabel mehr gehabt, unten ist
das Dashboard-Kabel hier so. Tja. Was hältst du vom neuen Microsoft Edge auf Chromium-Basis?
Also, ganz ehrlich, ich bin weder dafür noch dagegen, wir haben's ja hier installiert,
das Ding, das ist ja hier der Chrome, der Chrome Edge, man sieht's ja hier auch an Uplog
Origin. Ähm, warum nicht? Also, Microsoft sagt ja selbst, der hauptsächliche Grund
dafür, dass sie das ganze, was ist denn das für ein Gimmick? Nein, der hauptsächliche
Grund dafür, dass sie das ganze gemacht haben, ist, dass jemand anderes sich drum kümmert,
dass die Webseiten korrekt aussehen. Eigentlich eine ziemlich gute Idee, weil den Edge mussten
sie selbst dafür sorgen, in der Chrome-Engine kann ihnen das scheiß egal sein, die Seiten
sehen einfach richtig aus und es ist nur einfach so, dass heute die meisten Seiten im Chrome
entwickelt werden oder für Chrome entwickelt werden. Das ist jetzt nicht so das riesen
Ding, wie früher zwischen Mozilla und Internet Explorer und sonst was, aber es gibt schon
ein paar Sachen, wenn man die verwendet, geht's halt im Firefox nicht. Oh, das ist wieder,
das ist F-Zero-Musik, ne? Ja. Ja, steht zwar da, dass es Smash Bros. ist, aber das ist
ein F-Zero-Track. Poggers. Hallo, warum ist das jetzt so laut? Ich hab's so leiser gemacht.
So. Hast du einen eigenen Code-Style, wenn du nur für dich was programmierst? Hm. Also,
ich versuche eigentlich, mich meistens an das zu halten, was für die jeweilige Sprache
vom Hersteller so Style-Guide ist. Bis auf so ein paar Sachen, so ein paar Sachen verstoße
ich manchmal dagegen. Mir fällt jetzt leider kein richtig gutes Beispiel ein, aber wo
ich mich zum Beispiel nie dran halte, ist in C++, weil ihr wisst, dass für mich C++
die größte Kacksprache auf der Welt ist. Ich hab mich schon oft genug darüber ausgelassen
und da mach ich einfach so, dass es funktioniert und für mich am sinnvollsten erscheint. Zum
Beispiel mach ich den C++ manchmal so, dass ich keine Klassen verwende, ich zeig euch
das mal. Ich weiß, da wird sich jeder C++-Man sagen, Max, sowas kannst du doch nicht machen.
Aber guck mal, ich verwende beispielsweise hier keine Klasse, sondern hab das alles in
einem Namespace mit globalen Variablen drinne. Ich hab das aber an der Stelle nur gemacht,
weil das mit der Klasse nicht funktioniert hat, was ich machen wollte. Weil das ist ja
wieder so eine typische C++-Crap-Geschichte. Man kann in C++ keine C-Funktion, also man
kann keine Methoden von einer Klasse an alten C-Code als Funktionszeige übergeben, das
geht nicht. Also das heißt, mir blieb gar nichts anderes da übrig, wie das Ganze ohne
eine Klasse mit globalen Variablen zu machen, weil das C++ nicht supportet hat. Also man
kann, nur so, dass ich zu erklären, was man nicht machen kann. Also wenn ihr jetzt zum
Beispiel hier in C++, das ist schon wieder so typischer C++-Schwachsinn, ja. Also wenn
ihr jetzt hier eine Klasse in C++ macht, so und da drinne habt ihr, macht ihr irgendwie
eine Methode, keine Ahnung, void, blub, so, bester Name. Und ihr habt irgendwie noch eine
andere Methode, void, kappa, hd. Und ihr wollt jetzt eine C-Funktion mit einem Callback aufrufen,
C, Callback, Function, so. Was ihr nicht machen könnt, ist das hier. Das geht nicht. Also
wenn ihr wollt, dass diese C-Funktion quasi das hier als Callback aufruft, das geht nicht,
das ist nicht supportet. Das darf man nicht. Also das hier geht nicht, ja, aber weil es
die Funktion nicht geht, das ist nicht supportet. Wenn man das versucht zu kompilieren, sagt
er nein, man darf keine, keine Klassenmethoden als Raw Funktionspointer verwenden. Ist ja
schön und gut, aber es gibt keine Alternative für. Das ist so eine typische C++-Geschichte,
wo ich mir denke, ist okay. Also wenn jetzt nicht der Interop mit C in C++ gut ist, dann
weiß ich auch nicht. Das ist C++-Logik. Muss für die Uni Codestyle für C++ entwickeln.
Was, du musst einen Codestyle für C++ entwickeln? Warum nehmt ihr nicht den normalen recommended
Codestyle? Was aber auch witzig ist, so einen richtigen globalen Codestyle für C++ gibt
ja gar nicht, ne. Die einen sagen, man soll CamelCase machen, die anderen sagen, man soll
Snake. Ne, das ist nicht Snake. Ist das SnakeCase? Ne, wie heißt das hier Variable-Namen? Ist
das SnakeCase? SnakeCase ist doch, ne, das ist KebabCase. Ah ja, genau, das ist, das
ist, das ist SnakeCase, ne. Und, und KebabCase ist das hier. Das ist, das mögen die Javascript
Leute. Das finden die ganz, ganz super. Da sagen die. CamelCase. Ich muss sagen CamelCase
all the way. Also vor allem in C sharp CamelCase beste. In C++ nehme ich tatsächlich manchmal
SnakeCase, weil die eingebauten Sachen oftmals CamelCase haben. Da weiß ich, was von mir
das hier ist. Ja. Aber normalerweise nehme ich das, was vom Hersteller empfohlen wird.
Es gibt einen Punkt, wo ich mittlerweile in C sharp dagegen verstoße und zwar ist das
für Variablen, also für Klassenvariablen, die private sind, mache ich einen Anderscore
davor. Laut dem offiziellen Code-Guide, den es da von Microsoft gibt, ist das glaube ich
optional erlaubt, wenn sich, aber die empfehlen, dass man das nicht macht und private Variablen
kleinschreibt und dann this zum referenzieren verwendet. Kann man auch machen, wobei ich
mittlerweile, ich fand es am Anfang auch nicht gut. Könnt ihr euch noch dran erinnern,
von zwei Jahren oder so habe ich sogar noch gesagt, Leute ich mache lieber this und kleingeschrieben,
weil mittlerweile mache ich auch Anderscore. Beschäftigst du dich überhaupt mit Reverse
? Nee. Nicht wirklich. Ich meine ein paar Sachen habe ich schon über die Jahre mal,
nennen wir es mal Reverse-Enginiert. Kennt ihr mal noch Croof Shark? Das gibt es ja nicht
mehr. Kennt das zufällig noch jemand? Das war so ein Radiodienst, wo man kostenlos Musik
anhören konnte und die haben halt darauf aufgebaut, dass man halt das über die offizielle Seite
macht, mit dem offiziellen Player macht, dass die Werbung schalten können und sowas und
die haben den Fehler gemacht damals. Die haben ne Flash-Anwendung rausgebracht. Das ging
nicht in Deutschland so richtig, ja, aber man konnte die bescheißen. Und zwar, die
haben den Fehler gemacht, die haben ne Flash-Anwendung rausgebracht, ne Desktop-Flash-Anwendung haben
die damals rausgebracht und was ich damals gemacht habe ist, ich habe die Flash-Anwendung,
da gibt es so D-Compiler für Flash-Anwendungen, das ist total simpel was da rauskommt, da
kommt mehr oder weniger eins zu eins der Source-Code wieder raus und dann habe ich das Passwort,
was die verwenden um sich an ihre API zu authentifizieren, habe ich aus der Flash-Anwendung ausgelesen
und wisst ihr wie das Passwort war, heute kann man das ja verraten, ist ja kein Ding,
wisst ihr wie das Passwort war, war ein richtig geiles Passwort, mal gucken ob ich es noch
finde, mal gucken ob man es in Google noch findet, das Passwort war Quit Stealing My
Shit, aber es war ein bisschen Leadspeak geschrieben, das war nicht so geschrieben, es war ein bisschen
Leadspeak geschrieben, das war irgendwie Quit Stealing My Shit oder sowas, ne gibt es,
es hat man hat es ein bisschen anders geschrieben, aber so in der Richtung, so ein paar Kleinigkeiten
habe ich gemacht, also wie gesagt von den ganzen Reverse, was gibt es da, Ida, Pro und
Ghidra, ich weiß gar nicht wie man den ausspricht, Ghidra, wie spricht man das aus, Ghidra, Gaidra,
die coolen Leute, die coolen Leute sprechen das bestimmt Gaidra, Gaidra aus, Gaidra,
wir haben ja auch Leute die Hira, Gyra aussprechen und sowas, aber am besten, was mich immer
triggert Leute, Chat, Chat, ich sag es euch, das was mich echt triggert sind die Leute
die Ghidra aussprechen, da kriege ich echt Anfälle, wenn dann irgendwie einer kommt
mir der hat den Ghidra eingecheckt und sowas, in Ghidra, ja nachdem letztes Jahr der Vodafone
das System abgekackt ist, wo ich gerade einen mega Witz reißen wollte, wisst ihr wie das
Git Gui Plugin für Eclipse heißt, GIF versus GIF, eindeutig GIF, selbst wenn der GIF Erfinder
GIF sagt ist es nach wie vor GIF, zumindest das Git Plugin für Eclipse heißt, IGIT, passt
zu dem ganzen Kack oder, IGIT das ist der perfekte Name für den Eclipse Plugin, das ist genius
ja aber richtig, ok wenn man das nicht IGIT aussprecht, die coolen Leute müssten es
ja dann AYJIT aussprechen, das hört sich fast an wie irgendein türkischer Name, türkischer
Mädchen Name, wie heißt du AYJIT, das könnte echt ein türkischer Mädchen Name sein, klingt
irgendwie so, sowas haben wir ansonsten, klingt irgendwie so, wir hatten früher, wo wir gewohnt
haben im Haus eine, die hieß Ayshe Güll und die war keine Ahnung, das war, das war schon
eine ganze Weile, hey was wie alt wird die gewesen sein, 14, 15 oder so und die ist immer
draußen rum gerannt und ich hab die übelste Abneigung diesen Namen, weil die Eltern immer
aus dem Fenster geschrien haben, Ayshe Güll, die übelst lauten halben Tag haben die ihre
Tochter gerufen und da, also das ist das echte Name und der, der triggert mich, genauso wie
Mario, bei uns früher im Haus hat auch mal ein Mario gelebt und der hat permanent, permanent
hat er seine Frau und seine Frau ihn gerufen, auch so ein Ding er, es gibt schon ein paar
Sachen, die sind eigentlich ganz normal, aber, aber manche Leute nerven sie, weil sie halt
damit schlechte Erfahrungen gemacht haben, Robert, bei mir war es Mario, Mario und die
Frau hieß Angela, das weiß ich noch, da haben die, da haben die immer aus dem Fenster geschrien,
Mario, Mario und dann kam ich an, Angela, Angela, das war nervig, das, das, das war aber
richtige Unterschicht, das sag ich euch, was da gewohnt hat bei uns im zweiten Stock oder
so, das war wirklich komplett Unterschicht, anders kann man das nicht nennen, oh Max,
ich sehe, du willst Captain Affleck, ich kann dir gute Webseiten, Ressourcen geben, ich
weiß nicht, ob du noch schon da bist, gerade wieder, Bildungsfern sagt man, ja stimmt,
besonders, besonders, ja, mit besonderen Fähigkeiten, hey Max, du benutzt doch einen Mikrotik-Router
oder welchen hast du zur Zeit, ein Hex-POE, das habe ich glaube ich schon mal beantwortet,
wie sieht dein Arbeitsalltag im Homeoffice aus, das wollte ich tatsächlich mal in Ruhe
beantworten, das, das wollte ich mal wirklich in Ruhe beantworten, also sprich das da, weil,
das hat glaube ich Vodafone das letzte Mal, das Vodafone glaube ich das letzte Mal abgekackt,
das ich beantwortet habe, vielleicht, das ist Chat, was ist da?
Okay.
so ich schicke den jetzt gleich auf twitter was leute bin ich wieder da
gleich auf gleich geht gleich weiter geht gleich weiter
ich wie gesagt ich werde jetzt jeden tag voll spam auf twitter wie lang war ich jetzt
an 40 minuten
tweet geht raus ja mal gucken ob ich jetzt wieder hoch hoch schalten kann ja
beste musik jetzt leider bei jawoll
monka monka monka monka monka geht nicht
geht das läuft immer noch rund alter das das was was ich habe es noch gesagt
ne ich habe es noch gesagt dass das einfach nur wieder wieder flair flair
ausgestoßen von wo da vorne war
einmal geflehrt im heli haben sie mit dem dass man ticket geschlossen haben
die nupt fliegen den heli
so tweet ist raus
schau mal mal
schau mal was da heute kommt
jetzt kannst du wenigstens die umfrage zum kundenservice beantworten gute idee
mache ich jetzt gleich mache ich jetzt gleich wie zufrieden wie zufrieden waren
sie waren sie mit dem
kunde nummer ja wir wollen jetzt mal nicht so ist nicht so eng nicht so eng
seht oder geht das stimmt es überhaupt was geschrieben war 2 mbit upload und geht es damit jetzt halbwegs
geht so ich war zum glück reichen 2 mbit für den desktop betrieb so ansatzweise aus
ja
ja ihr dürft alle leiten alle leiten retweeten beste hauptsache dass den so dass
ihn so ein bisschen der arsch geht dass es halt auch die leute sehen weil ansonsten denken die sich
so leute wo bin ich wo bin ich stehen geblieben ich war gerade dabei beim
erzählen bei irgendwas von wo da vorne oder und in dem moment wo ich wo da vorne
erwähnt habe ist es abgekackt was was war was habe ich denn gerade erzielt
homeoffice richtig stimmt ich wollte die frage vom sebaro beantworten oder von
wem von den maligen wie wäre es mit einem tun das oder von kacke bild
automatisch einblendet wenn die frames trocken das ist eigentlich ziemlich
gute idee also wie sieht ein arbeitstag im homeoffice aus also bin ich da vor
da vorne kommen da bin ich übrigens auch die letzten tage übelste probleme im
homeoffice mit wo da vorne weil das ist ganz schön kacke wenn wenn in einer
teamsbesprechung bist und das komplett abkackt zwischendurch man könnte das ist
eine gute idee das ist eine richtig gute idee das muss uns gleich aufschreiben
leute machen wir mal so was wie hier projektideen wir machen einen tool tool
das automatisch wurde von service antwittert wenn stream lag das ist doch
was exzellent das machen wir demnächst
das ist eine gute idee es kam an bestimmt das kam an bestimmt recht easy
feststellen ob das stream gerade abkacken ist dann werden die richtig
folgespampt ist ja eh macht doch nix so gut so wunderbar die sollen ruhig
folgespammt werden
dann brechen auch die twitter selber zusammen wenn das also wenn nur ich das
macht dann geht das wenn das alle machen ist schlecht
leute ich habe re-subs übersehen nämlich vom bildschirm arbeiter und vom
jiu jim für einmal für sieben monat und einmal für zehn monate wahnsinn hyper
subscriber
massif iq chat wieder richtiger boost am start heute dank für die subs hast du
die webcam in teams an manchmal manchmal nicht oft
nicht oft also wie sieht denn gerade an arbeitsalltag im ok da kommen wir mal zu
der eigentlichen frage das war ich die ganze zeit schon beantwortet also bei
mir sieht das ungefähr so aus wieso machst du nicht einfach ein ordner für
die gifs das ist ganz einfach weil der chat sich
jedes mal freut wenn wenn man meinen desktop sieht stimmt jedes mal mein
desktop der desktop sieht macht der chat innerlich so
so also um jetzt mal die eigentliche frage zu beantworten also ich stehe so
irgendwie 7 30 oder so in dem dreh auf da muss ich erstmal kurz der katze was
zu essen machen dann gehe ich mal aufs klo und sonst was das führen wir jetzt
nicht weiter aus da mache ich den rechner an und lockt mich erst einmal ein eine
runde teams eine runde bei uns ist es bei uns ist es irgendwie zu tricks
remont lösung war mich nicht scheiß egal browser einloggen gut ist einloggen
gucken und da gucke ich mir erstmal die mails an und ob es irgendwie neue tickets
gibt oder sonstige geschichten habe ich gesagt ich mache mein pc aus ich mache
mein pc an warum soll ich mein pc ausmachen chat also chat manchmal ja
manchmal muss man schon bisschen mitdenken ihr wisst dass ich öfters mal
komisch dass ich öfters mal die wörter vertauscht ja rechner ausmachen macht
keinen sinn also da mache ich den rechner an der log ich mich ein da gucke
ich erst mal ob es neue tickets gibt ob e-mails gekommen sind ob irgendwas
passiert ist halt in der zeit wo ich nicht drauf geguckt habe und meistens
und ich glaube das habe ich letztes mal bis dahin habe ich das letzte mal ja
auch schon erzählt meistens ist dann auch schon irgendwas am start von
irgendwelchen leuten die die was haben wollen ich habe es euch ja ich habe es
euch ja schon zweimal oder so im stream gezeigt letztens hier fand ich auch
geil letztens per mail gekriegt hier morgens hier das da das habe ich euch
ja schon gezeigt so nachdem du könntest du diese
ändert mit der nötigen eile bearbeiten ausrollen habe ich geschrieben ja ich
bin heute nicht da wofür ist denn der fix und wie dringend ist das ja das ist
halt eine absolut exzellent exzellent fife hat high IQ antwort da hast du alles
mit abgehängt sagst einfach ja und daraufhin habe ich mich halt nicht
eingeloggt hab es erst mal ignoriert aber solche nachrichten kriege ich dann
meistens paar minuten nachdem ich gesagt habe dass ich nicht per mail des teams
ist das die weeps sind wieder unterwegs
so und ja wie gesagt meistens kommt dann irgendwie so was in der richtung das kann
sein von hier bitte mal ganz schnell fixen und es kommen auch leute die sagen
max ich habe mein git branche kaputt gemacht das sind die geilsten vor allem
wenn es java entwickler sind was auch immer vor allem wenn es java entwickler
sind das finde ich immer geil ich würde eigentlich erwarten dass im jahre 2020
das in der entwickler schafft so die so die geht basics zu beherrschen ja so die
so die ganz normalen sachen so die so so was weiß ich der kann sich der kann
den checkout machen in eigenen branche erstellen da drin paar sachen comitten
vielleicht ab und zu mal rebasen auf den master und und und und pull request
aufmachen viel man muss da eigentlich gar nicht können aber die meisten
entwickler bei uns die ja wenn es um skit händling geht machen die das eher
so und das schlimmste ist dann schon dass sie alle die java entwickler dieses
komische e-git eclipse plugin verwenden was die sache nicht besser macht ich habe
schon ich habe schon kommt ich habe schon histories gesehen von leuten die was
gemurtscht haben wollten da waren fünf leere comments drin weil das irgendwie
ihr e-git plugin gemacht hat
zumindest soll so nach ich kriege ich dann und ja wenn es um Hilfe max ich habe
meinen git branche kaputt gemacht ist das ist das manchmal ist das manchmal
ganz witzig weil dann muss man müssen wir erst mal erklären wie sie ihr git
branche kaputt gemacht hat heute ich höre mal auf zwischen den zwischen hell
und dunkel zu switchen das brennen mich das ist ziemlich pepega style wir warten
jetzt einfach mal bis unity media geantwortet hat in der zwischenzeit
erzähle ich weiter wobei die wahrscheinlich
wobei die wahrscheinlich nicht nicht antworten so schnell so und also da muss
man erst mal erklären wie sie denn ihre git branche zerstört haben da aber so
zwei da war so zwei fraktionen wir haben einmal die die wirklich gar keinen
blassen schimmer haben wie man geht verwendet aber es nicht zugeben wollen
und einfach irgendwas machen die kein plan haben die eigentlich nichts falsch
nichts richtig machen die einfach kein plan haben ja und dann haben die anderen
dies eigentlich können aber sobald was unvorher gesehen ist basiert
irgendwie in panik verfallen und dann komische dinge machen so die zwei
fraktionen haben wir bei den ersten da habe ich mittlerweile schon gar keinen
bock mehr denen zu helfen weil ich denke mir wäre es als entwickler oder als
admin oder als def ops man oder als service wer ist 2020 der ein bisschen
was mit it zu tun hat nicht schafft so die 45 basics git befehle kommandos zu
beherrschen der ist falsch falsch im beruf und da wenn das welche sind die
offensichtlich kein bock haben da habe ich auch kein bock mehr mittlerweile wir
haben beispielsweise einen das das ganz besonders toll
der sagt immer nicht ich habe kein plan ich habe kein plan der sagt immer ja
wo ist das denn dokumentiert und mittlerweile sage ich ihm ja lese
halt das offizielle git handbuch und bei der way das offizielle git handbuch
ist kacke und die git man pages sind auch kacke jetzt passt habe ich ich weiß
nicht ob ich es schon mal gezeigt haben kennt ihr die man page von git von git
pusch wer kann mir nach dem hit nach dem einleitungssatz der hilfeseite erklären
was git pusch macht
wer wer hat gedacht das ist ein guter einleitungstext wer hat sich das wer
hat gedacht so ja ja jetzt versteht man sofort was git pusch macht ich
exzellent ich habe das ist updates remote raffs using the local raffs
while sending objects necessary to complete the given raffs alles klar
exzellent exzellent exquisite anleitung geht aber wenn die leute nur nur fragen
können sie nach dem motto ja wo ist das denn dokumentiert da habe ich kein bock
mal drauf gerade externe gerade externe es kann nicht sein dass ein externer
eksperte berater wie auch immer dem anzunehmen zu dem thema im jahr 2020
keine 5 basic git befehle kann das geht nicht an das das kann nicht sein und ich
bin nicht dafür da den leuten die nicht willentlich sind sich mal ich erkläre
es ja jedem ich erkläre es auch jedem fünf mal aber beim sechsten war habe ich kein bock
mehr und da haben wir haben so ein kandidat der ist ganz besonders toll was
das angeht der fragt zu allem wirklich zu allem ja wo ist aus den dokumentiert zu
den zu den größten basics wo willst du denn wo landet man denn damit irgendwann
will er dann irgendwann wikipedia inhalt haben wir sein arbeit macht das
er quasi nur noch in die in die how to do work wikipedia gucken muss dass er dann
dann einfach oben anfängt und hat den tag erledigt oder was und vor allem wie
weit runter soll das dann eigentlich gehen so nach dem motto bitte jetzt
zeigefinger ausfahren auf den powerknopf drücken zeigefinger nach unten 30
sekunden warten wie soll das funktionieren ich stelle sich das vor
und gerade wie gesagt gerade als externer experte berater musste musste
das musste das muss er das gebacken kriegen und da gehe ich schon gar nicht
mehr darauf ein ist es mittlerweile wird sicherweise so dass die anderen
mittlerweile auch schon sagen ja guck mal du bist jetzt zwei jahre da
warum hast du es nicht mehr aufgeschrieben du hast schon dreimal
gemacht und dann ist er immer so wie der stolber früher und dann ist er
stinkig dann ist er stinkig danach weil man in der ex post hat ja so aber da
haben wir aber glücklicherweise nicht so viele und da habe ich dann auch keinen
bock mit den leuten zu helfen was was öfters was tatsächlich öfters
vorkommt ist ich weiß ich habe gesagt ich will nicht mehr zwitschen aber ich
muss die frage noch mal kopieren dass man sieht um was es geht kopieren wir die
mal dahin
genau und das da habe ich dann da habe ich dann schon schon kein kein bock
kein bock drauf an der stelle bei den anderen ist das überhaupt kein problem
da kommt öfters mal vor ist jetzt auch nicht immer so übertrieben wie ich jetzt
gesagt habe das was total kaputt ist aber was mir aufgefallen ist was wo die
leute beim beim gett händling ein bisschen probleme haben ist wenn sie
sachen machen in einem branche und dann versuchen den branche zu wechseln weil
dann müssen sie dann hast dann hast ja in das so zwei varianten das drei
varianten du hast eigentlich drei varianten entweder kannst du den
branche wechseln weil die dateien sich irgendwie nicht überschneiden und es ist
gut und du nimmst die änderung mit das wollen die meisten aber nicht die
meisten wollen dass die änderung in diesem branche bleiben aber so funktioniert
das paket nicht die änderung bleiben erst in diesem branche wenn du so
kommited hast aber das checken manche nicht so und dann zwitschen sie den
branche und es geht und kommiten sie im falschen branche falsche sachen oder
danach fragen sie sich hoch wo sind denn meine changes hin oder aber sie können
den branche nicht wechseln weil sie noch unkommittete sachen haben das verwirrt
oftmals die leute man muss aber auch sagen es ist nicht so schön gemacht
so die zweite variante ist anstatt dass das wechsel einfach funktioniert ist du
machst ein kommet dann ist die sache auch gegessen dann ist das in diesem
branche als neues kommet und du kannst wechseln machen was willst die dritte
variante ist du staschst das einfach für später das funktioniert auch
und da kannst du später weitermachen. Git stash ist eh eines der
usesten kommandos überhaupt ich sehe kaum leute das verwenden dabei ist das
eigentlich das beste das beste kommando für zwischendurch wenn man grad was
macht und der chef kommt zu einem oder irgendjemand sagt hier du musst jetzt
da und da was mal schnell machen dann stashst du deine endung wechselst in die
anderen branche machst die endung schnell dich an chef haben will
kommet ist das pusht das gehst wieder zurück
pops den stash und kannst an der stelle weitermachen wo du aufgehört hast also
ich popp also vielleicht liegt das daran dass ich dass ich gerne ins dash
poppe weiß ich auch nicht zumindest dass es sehr under used in git meinst du nee ich mein
das war es wirklich stash heißt
tom ux xx nee nee nee nee das stimmt nicht tom ux schreibt wir machen wir
machen jetzt mal sollen wir mal eine runde eine runde jit magic mit max
machen jetzt also tom ux schreibt was mich bei git am meisten abfuckt ist das
unbenennt von verzeichnissen dann geht die gesamte historie flöten das stimmt
nicht du musst das richtig machen du musst das mit git mv machen also wir
machen es hier test gibt ich habe keinerlei completion oder sonst was
installiert ist ein bisschen doof also wir machen jetzt eine datei cute chat
punkt txt 123 wir machen noch ein ordner mk dir blub so wunderbar aber geht status
gucken wir uns an uncommitted wir muven mal cute chat cute chat nach in den
ordner blub so als wenn man geht status da sehen wir okay und rechtfalls so wir
enden mal alles und wir machen ein kommet in it und gucken wir uns jetzt
durch anstellen fest macht das lokal aus hat ein kommet gemacht so und was der
tormox jetzt meint ist und da hat er nicht unrecht muss man sagen aber
was richtig macht geht's wenn man jetzt das hier macht wenn man den ordner jetzt
unbenennt move blub nach blub 2 geht status dann sieht man jetzt schon okay
für ihn sieht das so aus als ist die eine datei gelöscht und es gibt
komplett neue neue files und so macht man das nicht so macht man das nicht
weil geht denkt jetzt unter der haube ok die datei an dieser stelle wurde
gelöscht und es wurde neues verzeichnet mit der neuen datei die zwar zufällig
genauso heißt aber es ist ein neuer datei angelegt das denke der richtige
weg das ganze zu machen ist in status jetzt haben wir zurück brennen
der richtige das umzubinden ist das git mv muss du machen so wenn jetzt das
macht nach blub 2 und an geht status machte dann sagt er renamed
excellent
so muss man das machen tormox ich hoffe das hatte geholfen falls je nachdem wie
viele unbenennt und unbenennt willst aber das bringt was so wenn ihr das mit
rename macht dann ist nämlich auch die history in takt ich zeige euch noch mal
was was man jetzt machen kann was ultra praktisch ist was was
so was auch was auch sehr praktisch ist wenn man jetzt hier reingeht in in den
ordner und sagt okay ich meine meine history ist jetzt relativ überschaubar
also meine history hat jetzt zwei kommets da ist jetzt ist jetzt nicht so
viel wir brauchen mal wir brauchen mal den git repo wo mehr committed ist was
nehmen da jetzt kommt mir nicht mit dem linux kernel etwas mittel mittel großes
view gs github klonen wir jetzt mal da kann ich euch nämlich ein bisschen was
zeigen aber nämlich ein repo wo ein bisschen mehr dran ist da kommen zwar
nix da kann man zwar nix comitten was also excellent verzeichnissen haben
wenn noch so auskommen
da wird sich mein review freuen dass nicht so viel rot und grün ja und nachdem
ich bei uns ja der hauptsächliche reviewer bin freue ich mich bei sowas auch
so also wir haben jetzt mal das view gs repo geklont und was auch sehr praktisch
ist wir machen jetzt mal ein bisschen bisschen git match die kann ich euch ein
bisschen was zeigen ich meine es muss ja irgendeinen sinn haben dass ich den
ganzen tag diesen kram macht so wir nehmen uns jetzt mal in die in die
datei aus wie zum beispiel die ritmi ritmi hat ja fast jeder hat ja fast
jeder im repo im root verzeichnis liegen außer wir natürlich bei uns gibt bei
uns liegt keine ritmi datei im root verzeichnis bei uns liegt nur eine
change log datei im root verzeichnis wo man nachgucken kann zumindest wenn man
jetzt nachgucken möchte was hat sich alles an dieser datei geändert und wer
hat alles was an dieser datei gemacht da gibt es zwei varianten ich zeige euch
mal eine variante die ist zwar nicht so schön aber die ist bei anderen sachen
ganz praktisch ihr könnt sagen geht lock minus minus name only und dann seht ihr
alle commits inklusive den dateien die angefasst wurden
das ist ganz praktisch für ein bisschen überblick verschaffen will
was hat sich denn in den commits getan weil normalerweise sieht ein lock ja so
aus da sieht man nicht was sich geändert hat
so man kann nur angeben da sieht man auch zuletzt lichter was sich geändert hat
wenn man es ganz genau machen will macht man auch minus p dabei
ach das geht mit name only wohl nicht zusammen okay da kriegt man nämlich noch
das diff das ist eigentlich so eine sache die ich mir am tag 20.000 mal
angucken da kriegt man nämlich auch das diff zu den endungen was schöner ist wenn
man rauskriegen will was sich an der datei geändert hat ist man kann einfach
den geht lock auf die datei machen und dann kriegt man nur die kommets und ihr
seht da sind nicht viele das view report viel mehr kommets da kriegt ihr nur die
kommets die was an dieser datei geändert haben und dann könnt ihr euch das diff
zu angucken und so kriegt man richtig easy raus in welcher reinfolge wer was an
der datei kaputt gemacht hat das ist äußerst nützlich geht lock und dann auf
die datei machst du deine rift in der konsole ich wachte in der konsole zum
größten teil und schreibt dann in den polo quest halt an den jeweiligen
stellen was rein
so nächste geschichte wollte ich jetzt noch sagen nächste geschichte was man
machen kann was man probieren kann vielleicht bringt das nämlich wer hat
das eben gefragt dem tormox auch was was man probieren kann ist wenn sachen
hin und her geschoben wurden es gibt die option dass man noch
minus minus follow an gibt weil ich das richtig in erinnerung habe versucht
dass solche sachen wie renaming und sowas nach zu vollziehen dass man quasi
alle änderungen an dieser datei nach vollziehen kann auch wenn sie umbenannt
wurde ja so viel zu so viel zum datei unbedenken
eben geht es gibt ich wie gesagt ich kann euch da jetzt noch 100.000 100.000
andere geschichten zeigen ja vielleicht zeige ich das mit dem stash noch mal
vielleicht zeige ich das mit dem stash noch mal ich das sehr under just finde
deswegen gehen wir noch mal unser test repo zeigt das mit dem follow noch mal
ein tester gut da können wir nämlich mal ausprobieren ob das überhaupt stimmt was ich
erzählt habe also probieren wir mal aus geht plupp 2
sagen wir mal hier move cute chat nach cute cute chat 2 geht status aber mag er
nicht werden wir das ganze comitten das ganze bis big brain
guck da hat sogar schon gecheckt dass ich renamed hab da ist nicht blöd weil sich
nichts geändert hat in der zeit jetzt kann ich gar nicht zeigen
gut passt na gut an der datei hat sich ja so im moment
mein follow guckt seht ihr es funktioniert wenn ich ihn geht lock auf die datei macht
findet er nur vielleicht muss man das noch mal deutlicher deutlicher zeigen
wenn ich ihn geht lock macht auf die datei dann findet er nur das letzte
kommet warum findet er nur das letzte kommet weil ich ja nur in diesem kommet
diese datei überhaupt existiert mit dem namen oder weil diese datei erst
überhaupt ab diesem kommet existiert aber wenn ich den minus minus follow
dran machen dann versucht er auch renames nach zu
vollziehen und ihr seht ok die datei hier heißt die cute chat 2 jetzt noch cute
chat 1 aber er verfolgt das ganze hinterher so man könne es natürlich
auch name only dran machen dann sieht man auch aha hier war es cute
chat 2 und hier war es noch cute chat 1 das heißt die hat einfach eine nicht
richtig renamed die hat eine nicht get moved sondern die hat einer get hat
einer moved auf dem fallsystem das ist das ist ganz praktisch wenn was wenn
was nachvollziehen muss und das wichtigste kommando ever um sache nach
zu vollziehen können das mit dem stash zeige ich euch gleich die die die die
wichtigste sache um nachzuvollziehen können wer es verkackt hat ist ist und
bleibt das da geht play zeigt euch an wer in welchem kommet diese zeile in
der datei hinzugefügt hat beziehungsweise zuletzt editiert hat
sieht sehr unübersichtlich aus da kann ich euch empfehlen das tatsächlich nicht
auf der konsole zu machen sondern in dem editor oder so aber hier sieht man
komplett wer was gemacht hat in der datei also wir sehen zum beispiel dass
ihr den dennis oben das angepasst hat dann hat er der avenue das ist der
overview js mann ich finde es übrigens geil dass ich das dass ich avenue
spricht also so wie so eine straße quasi der das hier angepasst und so
findet man in kombination mit dem normalen lock und follow auf die datei
ziemlich schnell raus wie man wie man was machen kann
es gibt noch ein paar übelst abgedrehte tools um rauszufinden wann was kaputt
war da gibt es noch hier geht bisect und sowas das da will ich jetzt nicht so
sehr ins detail gehen das ist aber auch gerade für leute die so was machen
müssen wie ich öfters mal rausfinden wer es an welcher stelle kaputt gemacht
hat beziehungsweise welcher kommet es kaputt gemacht hat ist das hier eine
sache die man sich mal merken sollte das halbiert einfach immer die history
bis da fehler gefunden wurde das können wir irgendwann anders machen das ist
jetzt ein bisschen ein bisschen zu viel genau und ich wollte euch das mit dem
stash noch mal zeigen weil das mit dem stash
äußerst äußerst praktisch ist so wir gehen jetzt mal von aus wir machen
einen neuen wir haben einen neuen bratsch obwohl davon hat geantwortet
wo davon müsste gerade geantwortet haben
wo bitte melde dich dazu direkt noch mal per p.m. da können die zuständigen
kollegen sich direkt soll ich jetzt soll ich jetzt ich schreibe jetzt ich
schreibe jetzt das hier alte mmo alte mmo gewohnheit ich schreibe jetzt das in
die p.m. meld was soll ich denn sonst noch schreibe ich finde
ne ne ne die können ruhig du sagen ich sagte das juckt mich überhaupt nicht
die sollen den scheiß beheben die haben nette support grills die dürfen ruhig
du sagen das ist okay ja ich schicke das noch dabei
ok zack moment ich muss wundervon p.m. ich muss wundervon p.m. schicken
wo ist meine p.m. dieses twitter das twitter layout im browser wenn es zu
kleines da findet man auch überhaupt nix nachrichten wundervon
okay ich habe jetzt geschrieben meld was soll ich sonst machen
gut weiter im text um 10 macht das support der support hat bestimmt feierabend
erwarte ich heute abend jetzt auch nix so also stash wollte ich zeigen so was
auch was finde ich eines der under justesten geht sachen überhaupt ist mal
angenommen man ist jetzt in irgendeinem anderen branche trennen check out wir
gehen jetzt mal in den anderen branche in den eier ja das ist mein ach so minus
b das ist mein eier ja feature branche haben die nicht 24 7 ich glaube der
endkundensupporter mit den leuten die antworten 24 7 aber die leute die
wirklich was was was fixen an den geräten die haben bestimmt auch mal
irgendwann feierabend also jetzt sind wir in einem anderen branche wir machen
jetzt mal ein neuer teile keine hallo punkt txt so und jetzt haben wir eine
uncommittede datei und jetzt kommt der chef zu uns hat wurde auch noch nie in
techniker geschickt bis jetzt nicht eigentlich ist doch gar ganz gut weil
er müsste den weg freiräumen dass er da hinkommt ok also ich habe jetzt eine
neue datei angelegt hallo punkt txt und bin da gerade wild wild am editieren
trennen und zwar ich mache hier drin zum beispiel keine liste warum c++ sagt so
c plus c triple plus das ist sogar noch noch mal besser sagt so mache ich eine
tolle liste weil so und so und während ich am schreiben bin kommt mein chef
rein nach max ganz wichtig wir müssen was hotfixen weil das ist produktiv und
kaputt und sonst was ich ane ich bin auch gerade dabei mir eine liste zu
erstellen dass c++ scheiße ist aber kein problem ich mache nachher weiter
deswegen sage ich jetzt geht stash akumulat zahmar cheat 95 kann das sein
dass ich dich vorhin in irgendeinem anderen chat gesehen habe
ich bilde mir ein ich habe dich vorhin in irgendeinem anderen chat gesehen in
irgendeinem anderen programmier stream
dings hier von von von einem gott von einem deutschen spiele programmierer
der sich darüber ausgelassen hat wie scheiße es in deutschland in der spiele
szene zu arbeiten ich andi def genau ja ja stimmt
dann warst du das ok ich wusste ich dachte mir der name kommt mir irgendwie
bekannt vor ich habe das sogar rumgespammt vielleicht
dass mich auch gesehen so als ob max den andi def klar habe ich vorhin reingeguckt
so wie gesagt schäfer da gesagt jetzt müssen wir uns unbedingt machen aber ich
kann ja eigentlich gar nicht weil ich bin ja gerade dabei diese diese meine
liste zu editieren warum c++ sagt was ich jetzt nicht machen will ich will
jetzt noch kein kommet machen weil das ist ja noch gar nicht fertig also was
ich jetzt mache ist geht es also übrigens eine sache doch und das ist
das was viele auch verkacken wenn jetzt ein get checker und master macht nimmt
geht das standardmäßig mit also sprich die änderung die ich in dem anderen
branche angefangen habe nimmt damit so und das verwirrt viele leute so was man
jetzt machen kann ich edde die datei erste mal also dass das habe ich das
habe ich schon gemacht dann sieht man nämlich schöner ok und was ich jetzt
machen kann ist ich möchte jetzt diese datei erst mal weg haben aus meinem
working directory und nachher weitermachen also sage ich gibt's das
siehst du bem datai ist weg jetzt gehe ich in master da soll ich ja was für
mein chef machen und zwar soll ich hier cute chat 2 editieren da muss
unbedingt eine 4 hin weil der vorstand hat angerufen hat gesagt das muss mit
vier enden weil es muss durch zwei teilbar sein sonst ist die anzeige
raus und dann machen wir das
erkommitten wir das mit einer super tollen kommet message kappa poch hd
und dann sind wir fertig und jetzt wechseln wir zurück in unseren anderen
branche
und wollen weitermachen unserer z plus plus liste das problem ist jetzt wir
haben die ja gestascht also die ist ja gar nicht mehr da
deswegen sagen wir jetzt einfach geht stash pop und schon seht ihr ist das
ganze wieder da und wir können genau an der gleichen stelle weitermachen wo wir
vorhin aufgehört haben so sieht es aus also hallo andy der
also so könnte das einfach in eurem git repo machen wenn der chef reinkommt und
sagt danke für die erwähnung wie kommste ich habe bei mir im chat gerade
den cheat 95 wieder erkannt und habe ihn gefragt ob ich ihn nicht vorher
irgendwo in dem chat gesehen habe oder hat er gemeint ja war andy der stimmt
genau so sind wir auf die ganze geschichte geklappt ich wusste ich
wusste nicht mal genau wie der channel heißt ich habe gesagt ich war vorhin ich
habe dich vorhin in dem channel gesehen bei einem deutschen spiel entwickler
dass ich drüber aufgeregt hat wie scheiß ist in deutschland spiel entwickler zu
sein da hat er cheat gemeint das muss andy der gewesen genau ja ich habe
vorhin mal die ganze science and technology kategorie ein bisschen
durchgekuckt auf tritt schon ist mir aufgefallen dass es mittlerweile doch
recht viele deutschsprachige channels in dem bereich gibt es also viele vier
stück im vergleich zu früher
nee das war ich ich fand das gut ich es gibt auch so dinge ich habe auch so
dinge wo ich mich wo ich mich übelst übelst einfach einfach dringern lasse
chat sagt man was gibt es denn da so gefällt gerade nichts ein aber es gibt
dinge die muss ich auch jeden stream bestimmt dreimal erzählen
t plus plus richtig richtig t plus plus triggert mich auch immer ja
wo davon und wo davon auch ja und java stimmt was ich hier mache aktuell
ehrlich gesagt gar nichts ich habe gerade versucht den leuten irgendwie
pagittricks zu er zu zeigen aber eigentlich wollte ich nur gucken ob
wo davon wieder funktioniert und ich hatte für diesen stream heute absolut
kein plan was ich machen sollte ehrlich gesagt ja
ja wo davon hat geantwortet mal gucken ich habe vor davon auch gar von
schau mal was rauskommt was erzählen mal an die deft die
geschichte mit dem bahn klo das putet auch gar nicht das kann ich das ist die
bahn triggert mich auch oft du programmierst wohner vorn oder zum
glück nicht zum glück zum glück prokramiert nicht an wohner vorn rum
wo fuck
ach ja und solche nachrichten triggern mich auch auf der arbeite hatten was auch
gerade von ja
wo davon plus plus hör mal auf also wenn man zwei sachen verbinden könnte
die wo davon plus plus das passt eigentlich ziemlich gut zusammen das
sind zwei zwei sachen die sind zwar komplett passen überhaupt nicht
zusammen auf den ersten blick aber die haben sehr viel gemeinsamkeiten sitzt
der hast tiefer gegen wo davon oder gegen die bahn also man muss sagen
externe berater triggern auch ja externe berater triggern mich auch
manchmal man muss sagen ich hasse weder wirklich also hassen ist ich hasse
weder wo davon noch die bahn die regen mich manchmal auf aber von
hassen das würde ja bedeuten dass ich dass ich irgendwie persönlich irgendwas
gegen gegen den typ ab der in der bahn tickets kontrolliert also das ist ja
nicht so die können ja für den ganzen mist auch nichts genauso wenig wie die
service mit arbeiter hier bei wo davon irgendwas können wer dafür was kann
internet in deutschland ist auch so ein thema was mich was mich übelst triggern
oftmals
ja macht deine augenweite ist denn also wie gesagt ich hasse weder die bahn noch
noch wo davon noch sonst was vor allem schon gar nicht die mitarbeiter
mitarbeiter irgendwie von da von der bahn
ach moment war an die def jetzt mit mit seinem stream live in meinem stream oder
was das war jetzt aber stream stream section nun gut um was oder eigentlich
zurückzukommen wie gesagt ich hasse ich hasse die nicht ist schon schon ich hab
schon mal gar nichts gegen die gegen die service mitarbeiter oder so wo ich was
gegen hab ist zum beispiel der internet ausbau in deutschland
der geht mir echt auf den sack beziehungsweise was wir hier mit unserer
infrastruktur machen und das ist so ein thema das haben wo davon und die bahn
gemeinsam beides ist irgendwo infrastruktur und beides ist
infrastruktur da was eigentlich für die sagen wir mal sagen wir jetzt mal hoch
hochgesteckt sagen wir jetzt mal für die menschen im land da sein sollte ja
beides versucht geld zu verdienen und und meiner mein nach wo davon
ja wo davon ist da fast auf fast das meine ich noch noch mehr berechtigt
geld zu verdienen als die bahn weil ich finde gerade zur mobilitäts
infrastruktur genauso wie krankenhäuser und sowas soll nicht primär dafür da
sein um gewinn zu machen sondern quasi um die um die leute zu versorgen bei
wo davon muss ich sagen ok
wo davon darf schon das aus meiner sicht das ganze schon darauf auslegen gewinn
zu machen aber es gibt ja oftmals gar keine alternativen
die leute haben entweder den telekom oder wo davon was anderes gibt es nicht
und deswegen fehlen da auch die nötigen vorgaben irgendwie du kannst in
deutschland so eine kacke anbieten und die leute müssen es kaufen weil was hast
du denn für eine auswahl ich bin ja quasi schon gesegnet im endeffekt hast
du zufällig das neue video von simplicissimus gesehen die habe ich nicht
ich bin ja relativ gesegnet was das ganze angeht noch ich meine ich kann ich
habe die auswahl zwischen voter von 440 ab was macht die cia in frankfurt
nee was denn bei was bei was soll ich gucken vier minuten
das wohl wo steht hier vier minuten vier minuten 30
in frankfurt ist das größte us konsulat der welt perfekt um camp aufzuschlagen
wenn man dann zum beispiel den französischen präsidenten belauschen
will setzt sich ein cia agent einfach in frankfurt in einen zug und kommt nicht
an er wieder aus weil die bahn nicht fährt und
versteht was wir meinen genauso ist es so sieht es aus
irgendwie erinnert mich die stimme von dem wissen wir nämlich erinnert das ist
mir das fällt mir jedes mal auf wenn ich die die videos von ihm anhöre
perfekt um camp aufzuschlagen er erinnert mich übertrieben an ihn hier
von der stimme her falls sie nur irgendjemand kennt
die fordernden spielberichterstatter mit nah mit seiner youtube stimme vielleicht
weniger aber wenn man so mit ihm im skype gelabert hat hat sehr ähnlich
angehört freiheitsliebende auch sozusagen so und damit sage ich mal
herzlich willkommen habe heute finde ich auch schon angekündigt also ein bisschen
ein bisschen aber wenn er normal redet und nicht seine commentary stimme am
start hat dann dann hört sich das wirklich ziemlich ähnlich an
direkt übertragen nicht gleich erst mal zur linken seite der karte wir können
mal sagen hier das hat schon hat schon gewisse ähnlichkeit ja oh gott noch
skalli ja stimmt stimmt ist blöd dass so viele leute weg sind so das habe ich
euch ein bisschen jitt jitt magic gezeigt zum abschluss hier noch
beenden wir die eine frage noch dass ich nächsten striem nicht wieder davon
anfangen muss nämlich das hier was das in bau gefragt hat wie das bei mir
daheim aussieht mit mit mit home office wie gesagt ich habe mich jetzt ein
bisschen über git geschichten ausgelassen leute dies verkacken so da
kommen natürlich noch ein paar andere sachen dazu es kommen irgendwelche
täglichen meeting geschichten dazu da gibt es wartungsarbeiten runden und
und von unserem service 24 sieben support es ist kein 24 sieben support
nicht das stimmt so nicht von unserem monitoring team da haben wir einmal im
tag eine runde wo ich mich dabei hocke dann haben wir ab und zu team runde da
haben wir irgendwelche abteilungs runden also es wird es wird öfters wird öfters
mal gemietet und da gibt es manchmal tage da hast du wirklich fünf sachen
wurde ganz nach nichts anderes macht außer sinnlos mieten das sagt natürlich
aber was willst du machen letztendlich wenn man unter dem
strich betrachtet ich habe ich habe aufgehört mich da so so extrem darüber
aufzuregen wenn zu viel gemietet wird weil ich denke mir die haben die haben
zwei sachen zur auswahl die können mich dafür bezahlen dass ich was sinnvolles
mache oder die können mich dafür bezahlen dass ich rum sitze und nix
mache also und wenn man die wahl hat und man wählt ich soll rum sitzen und nix
machen ist das auch vollkommen in ordnung
vollkommen in ordnung er schied 95 da ist er recht
ja zu zählen zum thema merckst du jetzt bin ich ja noch gar nicht gekommen so
und dann kommt ganz drauf an was an diesem tag ansteht gibt es irgendwelche
neue releases müssen irgendwelche sachen getestet werden müssen irgendwelche
sachen gehort fix werden müssen irgendwelche sachen dokumentiert werden
müssen vielleicht vielleicht irgendwelche automatisierung sachen ein bisschen umgeskriptet werden oder sonst was
irgendwas was halt in meinen bereich noch fällt gibt es vielfältige sachen die
sein können das mache ich den restlichen tag über ja ja leider leider muss ich
sagen ist in letzter zeit ich habe es ja schon mal gesagt
leider ist in letzter zeit ein bisschen wenig selbst programmieren angesagt
leider ist ein bisschen wenig selbst programmieren angesagt so die letzt
ist eigentlich schon die letzten paar jahre so aber was ich so aber dafür habe ich
die da dafür habe ich ja den chat und mein rumgebastel hier auf twitch
da muss ich dann nichts mehr programmieren was ich letztens
gebastelt haben was weiß ich was ist was tatsächlich ganz cool ist unser support
von dem ich gerade erzählt habe unser monitoring anguck team ich kann ich kann
ich kann nicht wirklich sagen wie das team heißt weil das ist ein ziemlich
unik name den sonst keiner verwendet also wir haben ein team das ist quasi quasi
so es ist nicht wirklich eine art es ist nicht wirklich in first level aber ich
beschreibe ihn mal als first level wir haben ein team das hat so ein operation
center ist das quasi ja können operation center nennen die haben alle
monitorin mann gucken ob da irgendwelche monitorin geschichten aufschlagen ob
jetzt irgendwelche fehlermeldung kommen und dann leiten sie halt die notwendige
entstörung und koordination in die wege ja so operation hauptquartier so was
in der richtung genau und jetzt habe ich vergessen was ich damit genau und da
kommen manchmal leute auf die glorreiche idee dort etwas brain debt
aufgaben abzuladen weil so nach dem motto ok die sind eh 24 7 da das heißt
man kann da auch die unnötigsten aufgaben wo man keinen bock hat sich drum
zu kümmern hin hin verlagern so und wir haben einen externen anbieter für spam
filtern wir filtern zwar intern auch mal spam aber wir haben noch einen externen
anbieter weil unsere reputation für mail relay nicht gut genug ist da sind
vergleich spam wir machen das über den externen anbieter zumindest ist der mail
filter von dem externen anbieter ein bisschen sehr scharf eingestellt und es
kommt vor dass mails die quasi kunden bei uns verschicken über unser system
dass die als spam klassifiziert werden
und die landen dann im spam ordner und die kann man relativ einfach erkennen
anhand der absender adresse so und da kam jetzt irgendjemand auf die idee und
musste entscheiden ok wir geben das unseren programmierern die das mal
ordentlich programmieren dass das spam system nicht so viele anhaltspunkte für
spam findet und die mails gar nicht im spam ordner landen das war das war die
das war die eine möglichkeit die zweite möglichkeit war wir geben das unserem
24 7 support dass der einfach fünf mal am tag ins web interface geht und spam von
hand frei gibt ratet mal für welche variante man sich entschieden hat für die
five hat variante richtig warum trendet festsplatte eigentlich watt
management genau also die hatten den auftrag sie müssen das ganze sie
müssen das ganze manuell von hand frei geben was natürlich ziemlich sagt habe
ich mir gedacht ok tun wir den mal gefallen und basteln was was was ihnen
hilft das war eines der sachen die sie letztes
einmal wirklich wieder programmiert haben und zwar habe ich was kleines
gebastelt dort net core weil wenn ich eigene projekte
macht die wodurch dran beteiligt mir ganz ohne problem in dort net core machen
da muss kann ich ja was nehmen was womit ich klarkommen womit kein anderer
klarkommen muss habe ich dort net core projekt gemacht so dass es halt auch
unterlinungs läuft und hab das automatisiert so funktioniert folgendermassen
es ist relativ klein was hat das am ende 400 zeilen oder so also es ist recht
recht überschaubar oder 500 ist nicht so viel ist recht überschaubar so und was
es macht im endeffekt ist es nimmt nen embedded embedded chromium nimmt das hier
das da
damit kann man nämlich den headless chrome den headless chrome starten aber
du wurdest nicht beauftragt das zu machen doch wurde ich ich hab mich selbst
beauftragt indem ich zu meinem chef gegangen bin hab gesagt er soll mich
beauftragen und dann bin ich zum chef gegangen vom vom support und habe
gesagt er soll mich beauftragen und beide haben ich beauftragt easy schon
als auftrag auf geht's
das hat ja auch nicht lang gedauert halb tache oder so
ja zumindest ist das ding hier echt praktisch das hat nen embedded chromium
ein embedded headless chromium chrome wie auch immer also sprich man kann das auf
einem kommando zeilen system ausführen und dort in webseiten den chrome in
webseiten rumklicken lassen ohne dass man eine grafische ausgabe braucht das
was habe ich gemacht ich habe nen browser plugin genommen das user eingaben
aufzeichnet hab diesen ganzen vorgang was heißt headless ohne ohne grafische
ausgabe also nun chrome ohne dass du dieses fenster hier siehst aber der
trotzdem läuft und webseiten aufmachen kann den kannst du dann halt über
dieses über diese programmierstillstelle steuern
das heißt du klickst da nicht das heißt du klickst da nicht hier drauf du sagst
dann newtab navigate ull klick das macht das hier warte auf
seitenladen so art selenium ja plus das pappertier ist kein dotnet program
pappertier ist das offizielle das offizielle chromium automatisierungsding
glaube genau headless chrome node.js api 61.000 sternen hat das bem system keine
api nein sonst hätte ich es da drüber gemacht und sie haben auch nicht vorher in
zukunft eine wir haben wahrscheinlich für die letzten crap anbieter gewählt
oder eine kacklizenz oder was auch immer so zumindest im prinzip unter der haube
habe ich habe mitgeschnitten mit einem browser plugin was das auf der seite
macht und habe das dann ein bisschen vereinfachter form in dieses in das dotnet
core programm gepackt hat ein paar sachen drumherum gebaut das ist eine
schöne log datei schreiben was es gerade macht wie viele sachen sie freigegeben
hat und die premium lösung leute die premium lösung die ich eingebaut habe
nachdem es mit gelockt hat welchen spam es freigibt geht es und das jetzt kommt
jetzt kommt absolut big brain time danach wenn es was gemacht hat lockte sich bei
unserem ticket system ein wir haben wir haben so einen extra user für für
script zugriffe lockte sich bei uns über die jira api im ticket system ein
sucht das letzte ticket was mit dem titel mit dem titel spam freigeben oder
sowas sucht das letzte ticket also ordnet sucht alle tickets mit dem titel
ordnet es nach nach zeit geht in das letzte ticket rein und schreibt dort und
postet dort drinnen in comment wie viele spams es gefunden hat und wo auf welcher
email adresse und wie viel es freigegeben hat und dadurch dass es in
diesem ticket benachrichtigt gibt es automatisch den alert vorne auf der
monitor wand dass das ticket geupdatet war das heißt alles was die leute noch
machen müssen ist zu warten bis das script alle 15 minuten einmal gelaufen
ist das ticket geupdatet hat und dann können sie sagen ok alert ist da sie
gucken das ticket rein gucken sich den reporter machen das ticket zu
klicken
ja
gibt es die premium lösung auch erst nach einem in app in store sollte ich
vielleicht mal überlegen sowas ja fati schreibt schreibe aktuell ein
pappetier script welches datum aus der excel datei unsere sap zeit erfahrt
i geht also da sieht man schon mal dass beide scheiß software ist weil wenn man
weil wenn man das über den umweg eines headless
chrome's machen muss ist entweder das zielsystem kacke oder das
quelsystem kacke dein script ist bestimmt gut ja aber allein schon dass
man sowas dafür braucht ist absolute brain dead und wie entscheidet das script was
was spam ist das ist ganz einfach das entscheidet es auf dem gleichen weg wie
das ein menschlicher freigeber entscheiden würde nämlich alles was
von einer speziellen email adresse kommt wird freigegeben und wir haben auch schon
wir haben auch schon den übelsten mist freigegeben ich kann mich noch dran
erinnern also die anweisung ist klar die anweisung die die haben ist jede mail
die dort mit dieser email adresse mit dieser mit diesem wildcard filter im spam
ordner landet muss freigegeben werden da steht ganz klar eine arbeitsanweisung
für die leute drin und eines tages kann der stelle auch noch mal zählen
eines tages wurde sich ein bisschen darüber beschwert weil irgendeiner eine
harry pussy mail gekriegt hat und die wurde natürlich auch freigegeben aus
dem spam ordner oder hat er sich beschwert dass er eine harry pussy mail
gekriegt hat und da haben wir gesagt ja gut also was heißt wir der support das
operation center wie auch immer man das endbar hat gesagt die die anleitung ist
klar alles freigeben mit dieser email adresse
und genau das gleiche macht man skript kann man da keine regeln auf nein kann
man nicht das das ist wirklich das spam anbieter das webinterface ist der
letzte krabb
ok leute fragen sie mit gelockt was habt ihr für den ticket system hier
wusstest du dass die nase apis anbietet nee leute ich gucke mir die frage
nächsten mal an ich wollte ja eigentlich nur checken ob
wo davon funktioniert wir feststellen dass wo davon nicht funktioniert was
den baro was meinst du was haben wir uns vorgestellt hat wie
wir so haben sich so was die kollegen nicht selbst geschrieben ich glaube das
ist recht recht simpel entweder war keiner da das konnte oder die
skorten hatten kein bock gehabt also ich tipp mal drauf dass das für unseren für
die meisten leute die dort im operation center support arbeiten nicht unbedingt
das skill set ist was sie besitzen das habe ich jetzt schön ausgedrückt oder
für die meisten können es nicht
ich sage nicht wie das beim anbieter heißt
sebaro das oben geschrieben was wir uns darunter vorstellen ja was genau habt
ihr euch da eigentlich vorgestellt was wollt ihr baut
die entwicklung des archivs ich habe mir da noch gar keine gedanken drüber
gemacht aber das schreiben wir jetzt mal in stream ideen rein
wo plus punkt tv archiv einfach eine suchmaske
irgendwas eine suchmaske und fast wo du einfach hochladen kannst
was ich da habe ich habe mir noch wenig gedanken drüber gemacht
discord ja wir haben einen discord noch mal ausgleichen discord
ja ich weiß dass es alles in google drive hofft das macht aber nix das ist
ok wir machen einfach ein upload wir machen
dann einfach dann ab den upload fällt für dich da kannst du kannst du in
google drive hochladen du kannst in google drive hochladen muss danach halt
irgendwie einfach den link den link irgendwie mal irgendwo rein pasten und
dann dann liest er sich das den titel aus und schreibt in irgendwie in es
gleich datenbank oder irgendwas mal gucken
leute ignoriert das was im chat steht wenn in discord kommt geht nicht in den
weep spam channel das ist mein ernst das ist hochgradig
hochgradig verstörend also das erste ich muss ja einmal im tag in den weep
channel gucken weil ich halt den channel markieren muss für gelesen und das
erste was man da sieht sind irgendwelche hentai tentakel titties und zeugs und
alles also das wollen wir nicht sehen als erstes im chat wer sehen will
danach kann sich das angucken guckt da nicht rein guckt euch die
anderen channels an
rechts links stumm schalten ja ich weiß das mache ich zum größten teil auch cute
content jeder jeder wie er will für die für die weeps unter euch ihr wisst ja
dass ich eigentlich seltenst irgendwelche animes oder irgendwelche
japanischen japanischen content konsumiere aber ich muss sagen ich habe
wirklich in anime geguckt letztens und zumindest die ersten drei folgen und
und noch nicht mehr aber ich werde wahrscheinlich noch fertig gucken ja
selber stellen es vor tatsächlich tatsächlich kein kein porn was normales
dinks hier wie heißt das into abyss oder so dass er das heißt letztens
amazon prime gesehen da rief es auch
ansonsten gucke ich ja gucke ich ja wenig
so leute wir sehen uns ich muss jetzt echt pennen morgen wahrscheinlich wieder
streamen bisschen technik kram dann heute war ja nur einfach so random wir sehen
uns macht's gut bis den chat weiß was wir horsten jetzt den
an die def komm wir horsten jetzt den an die def oder kommen wir an die an die
def vor an die def an die def vor an die def den ort in den reiten auswärts kommt der hat's verdient
rate
hallo
geht das bauisch der rate ist kaputt bei mir
der rate ist kaputt bei mir
ich kann den rate nicht auslösen
ich kann eigentlich ich sehe das fenster nicht um den rate auszulösen
ich muss auf meinen chat neu laden
ah jetzt jetzt geht's jetzt geht's ok leute wir sehen uns bis zum nächsten
mal macht's gut zu